direction la tchétchénie maintenant
quarante jours après l'assassinât de la
journaliste anna politkovskaïa qui
dénonçait les exactions nous avons
souhaité revenir sur la normalisation en
cours entre guillemets il faut savoir
que la province est désormais gouvernée
par un protégé de vladimir poutine
ramzan kadirov fils du président
assassiné il ya deux ans il a à peine 30
ans est un ancien lutteur et chef de
milice il affiche ses goûts de luxe sans
complexe et la population épuisé par des
années de guerre semble se rallier à sa
cause
malgré les protestations des défenseurs
des droits de l'homme c'est le dossier
de cette édition il est signé anne
ponsinet volodia polanski
ramzan kadirov a beau dire que la
tchétchénie est pacifiée autour de lui
ça ne saute pas aux yeux
il ya tellement d'hommes en armes même
ce jour là lors d'une course de chevaux
à l'honneur de son fils l'entourage du
premier ministre reste celui d'un
guerrier
rien d'inquiétant selon lui le guerrier
de b celui qui gère au lieu le patron
joe son père ex président de la
tchétchénie est mort victime d'un
attentat en mai 2004 il était l'homme de
moscou
le jour même de sa mort dont vladimir
poutine reçoit son fils un jeune kadyrov
sous le choc
à 27 ans il n'a alors pas l'âge requis
pour succéder à son père il devient vice
premier ministre fut premier ministre
en réalité à la tête de ces milices
c'est lui l'homme fort de tchétchénie
théoriquement ces milices sont
aujourd'hui intégrées les forces
régulières russe et sur ses portraits
ramzan pose désormais en reconstructeurs
de fait
grozny change mais à quoi bon tous ces
travaux si les gens eux ont toujours
peur peur de ce qui est arrivé à issa
son fils arrêté il ya un an par des
hommes subordonné à ramzan kadirov il sa
montre à l'om j'ai mémorial qui suit son
dossier comment son fils a été torturé
pour qu'il avoue un meurtre et sur les
jambes et sur le dos c'est pareil
à l'époque les habitants du village
avaient manifesté et le père a porté
plainte pour détention illégale
une détermination assez rare parce que
les gens ont peur - par deux fois on m'a
mis un automatique sur le ventre et on
m'a dit si tu ne te calmes pas on va te
descendre g kadirov ni les exactions
dont on l'accuse
il ne reconnaît que des dérapages comme
par hasard le cas d'un de ses anciens
frères d'armes devenu un ennemi en ce
qui concerne les enlèvements
oui ça existe où nous avons nous même
révélé une histoire concernant mavs la
daba y sa robe
le commandant du groupe que j'ai dirigé
à l'époque il y a des moments où nous
mêmes ne sommes pas aussi propre que
nous le voudrions
le journal de anna politkovskaïa avait
reçu plusieurs vidéos qui prétendait le
démasquer ici sur ces images à peine
lisible des hommes armés ont fait en
plusieurs personnes dans des coffres de
voiture kadirov est là les victimes
étaient des policiers ivres dit il je
suis arrivé j'ai regardé j'étais en
voiture
et voilà on dit que kadirov les bas et
les enlève cette politkovskaïa je ne
sais pas pourquoi elle voulait tellement
dire du mal de moi mais tout ça ne
justifie pas que des hommes même
policier ivre se retrouvent dans les
coffres de voitures question ramzan
kadirov premier ministre et probable
futur président de tchétchénie at il la
volonté et les moyens de rompre vraiment
avec la guerre en garantissant les
libertés publiques
en bref le